awesome thank you so much for having me
it's fantastic it's actually my first
talk that I do my first Tech Talk that I
do in Asia so I'm really really keen to
get your feedback as I already got
introduced my name is Timothy Schmidt we
probably long as the most German name
you will ever see in your life and I
think Thomas made a good kind of
approach over here there can be only one
German evangelist per conference day
because otherwise that's kind of too
much my topic today is no J's
application and data security which
means I'm going to go a bit into kind of
the key problems that we as developers
face when we implement authentication
systems when we have to deal with data
hardening this key stretching with
public key private key encryption
mechanisms hashing and I talked about a
few of those kind of learnings that I've
seen when we looked at different
companies that's deal with this so I
work for Braintree which is part of
PayPal and Braintree is a payments
company that deals with a lot of mobile
payments but still obviously PayPal as a
bigger corporate deals with a huge huge
infrastructure which actually runs
mostly on OJ's nowadays so that's where
my interest comes from a few words about
myself because before I get started you
can find me on Twitter that's me
I used to be a developer actually coming
from a mobile background so I used to
work on Windows Mobile and that stuff
and it actually still existed I earned
money working for Samsung as a kernel
developer for android and i'm actually
offering a book on node.js security at
the moment with o'reilly and i've been
evangelizing for companies for more than
five years so you probably saw me at
some mobile event or something like that
I live in the beautiful town of Berlin
which is always worth the trip so I can
only but recommend going there but since
I evangelize in a global team and I run
the
European and Asian team for us I kind of
live a van at an airport so probably if
you ever seen a Berlin airplane there's
a good chance that I actually sit in
there and there is like a secret
handshake between all of us Everland
frequent fliers all three of us so if
you ever see one of us think of me
alright so again brain is a paper
company got acquired in 2013 and our
developer facing side is pretty much
Braintree so let's dive into the talk
today I as I said before I dive into a
few different things and I want to start
with a very simple analogy then I go
into a couple of different security
threats that we see over and over again
and then I want to go into data
encryption obviously since Express is
still kind of a weapon of choice for
most know developers I go into how we
deal with making express more secure and
how we kind of work on a more defensive
kind of coding approach I also go a bit
into Khoa I talk about middleware and
then I point out a couple of really
awesome resources that help me
researching this talk and that helped me
researching for my book as well I want
to start off with an analogy that I love
I used to be I'm actually still a geek
but I used to be a huge geek for kind of
mythology and history and all that stuff
when I was growing up anyone in this
room recognizes this handsome young man
just raise your hand if you do that all
right awesome so the person that you see
on this image which is an image from
more than thousand years before Christ
is Hercules or Heracles which used to be
a demigod a half guard vision of Zeus
and a simple woman and the issue was the
stepmother of Hercules drove him mad
so he did a lot of bad stuff he killed a
couple of people that he shouldn't have
killed and so on he wanted to do get
Redemption he wanted to be redeemed and
wanted to kind of save
via limps make everything up what he did
so they gave him a couple of different
tasks to kind of make up for his work
which is known as me twelve labors and
one of those tasks was killing a Hydra
if you don't know hydras they are huge
badass snakes with a lot of different
hats if you chop off her head a new head
grows so that's kind of unhandy right
because it's really hard to deal with so
Hercules had this big mace over there
that you see in his hand and he but I
like punched the Hydra and tried to kill
it but big heads keep on growing and
growing and be Hydra keaton regenerating
so he struggled so Hercules ran away got
his friend he allows who was a security
engineer and they figured out I should
probably just patch that so they use
poisons and they poison the Hydra and it
actually worked so I feel securities of
very similar to the Hydra we close some
bugs we close some issues in a new thing
appears and then we close that issue and
we work on that issue and a new thing
appears and there is a constant kind of
treadmill where we as developers have to
keep up with all those issues right a
lot of developers tend to care for
security when it's too late that's a bit
like speeding on a highway normally
people speed on a highway drive
incredibly fast then they get a ticket
and then they start driving slow
it's the same with security a lot of
developers sadly don't care for security
until it's actually too late until
something bad happens and then we up our
game and I feel like there is actually a
lot of amazing resources and a lot of
great open source and amazing tutorials
that actually help us not making the
mistakes of other people again and again
obviously there's always the tech side
of things there's always what we as
developers can do and then there is
always the human element that's always
these are the things that we don't
necessarily control where we have to
work at education and we have to work
with culture and it turns out human
beings are often attacked lazy so let me
give you a very quick example in 2014
the top 10 passwords were really
hilarious
people are lazy they like to like speed
up things they like to skip logins and
they like to kind of just get to a point
in time very quickly so the issue is
password like password because what can
go wrong
QWERTY and Germany that will be creates
baseball that's only the Americans I
guess dragon so that works over here
there's a lot of those kind of things
that we actually realize passwords are
sometimes a bit ridiculous and passwords
are actually very very kind of prone to
pop culture passwords change over time
and that's not just for singer
individuals that's something that we see
on a global scale so we see if we look
at those lists and there are lists with
like thousands and thousands of popular
passwords that's a lot of interesting
things appear let me give you a good
example
any Marvel fans over here Marvel Comics
awesome Batman and Superman made it to
place number 21 and 24 any clue why
there's a movie coming out the next year
Batman vs Superman so this actually
makes choices like Batman and Superman
incredibly popular you will see artists
and they're like Lady Gaga on Justin
Bieber and probably if you use Justin
Bieber as a password you deserve to be
hacked sorry if any a Justin Bieber fans
are in the room I totally appreciate
that so I think there's a lot of stuff
that we as developers obviously have to
do over here and that starts with simple
things like educating people and good
nightly mainstream media is slowly
catching up so we see articles about
weak passwords about how to create
secure passwords and all that stuff in
mainstream media we see like big
journals like The Guardian like Wall
Street Journal and so on actually
educating people about this so this is a
good start but changing culture
especially to habits is something that
takes a long long time and if we look at
passwords it is a bit weird that
how we work in the internet especially
my JavaScript scene changes every
Tuesday and there is always a new
framework and we adopt two new
technology and we learn everything but
then we use those very old kind of
fashioned approaches like username and
password for login and that is something
that we've used hundreds of years ago
already right and the issues never
changed
passwords are being phished they are
being key locked
they are simply reused and you see that
in those top thousand lists or even
bigger lists so there is a lot of kind
of issues that we have over here then if
we talk about authentication we always
have to talk about an authorization as
well and there are popular standards
like o of 1 or 2 up my D up my D
connects and all that different kind of
things which tend to do a lot of the
same things but there is a key
difference between authentication which
means I want to prove that it's really
me standing in front you it's about the
identity of a person and authorization
which means I want to give access to
resources
I want to grant access to certain things
which can be a profile but also just to
prove a picture or something else right
and those are key issues and key
differences that we sometimes just
simply ignore there is this list of
interesting vulnerabilities which is
called the OAuth top 10 which is the
open web application security council
and security projects and we lay this
list that they released was in 2013 and
they go through the top 10 issues that
they see across hundreds and thousands
of applications we first run a simple
injection which can be LDAP injection
which can be SQL injection and so on and
what we simply do over here is we trick
the interpreter and into executing
commands that shouldn't probably be
executed right and everybody probably
tried writing drop table in some kind of
input form before it had fun doing that
right and people do that and people try
that it is very simple but it's actually
quite critical broken authentication
systems this can deal too
this can cause big big issues so we see
that session management is a good
example people not actually signing
session cookies we see no kind of
hashing or we caching no encryption or
weak encryption and so on that obviously
causes issues again a lot of sites still
provide the session ID in the URL and
you can read that and it's usually
sequential or something which is not
that's not right
because if I see my session and I see my
next session ID I can probably guess
what the coming session ID is cross-site
scripting incredibly popular and still a
very relatively severe threat so
cross-site scripting or XSS is pretty
much the fun of the kind of inserting
scripts into a site and the browser and
besides trust each other and that's a
trust relation it so more than
templating engines tend to kind of
sanitize data and that it tend to encode
different characters and so on and that
all is great but we still end up
evaluating different things right and we
can still trick different routes and to
actually edit executing things we don't
want there is a difference in reflective
cross-match cross-site scripting which
means it is just executed once and
persistent cross-site scripting where we
can actually access the database right
stuff and execute that over and over
again so in this case we accept we
exploit the trust of our browser and the
user into a site and if you have used
forums back in the 90s you probably know
that we were able to use bbcode and that
stuff to execute script tags and handle
lots of fun popping up with alerts and
even worse things so i'm object-- that
references where no access level control
is being made that is actually still an
issue the amount of sites that only
protect certain resources but actually
ignore protecting all resources that's
hilarious
so objects can be manipulated I get
access to certain fields of objects that
should probably not be able to menu play
it and those are sometimes really simple
things that can lead to a big big issue
misconfigured applications you would
wonder I actually talked to the bunch of
guys from Heroku and other companies
that do cloud hosting and they said the
amount of apps that go onto their
services and that still run on a
development environment today instead of
actually switching over to production
modes or that shape their credentials
somehow and they messed that up there is
a lot of those things where miss
configuration can lead to a lot of big
issues like actually showing error
messages instead of using them and like
consuming and gracefully on your site
exposure of data where again encryption
plays a huge role and public key private
key sometimes sounds a bit complicated
there is still way too few sites using
HTTPS probably and part of that is
because SSL and TLS are sometimes a bit
clunky to use so we see a lot of those
sites that don't really rely on
transport layer security again access
layer control verifying requests making
sure that users are actually allowed to
do certain things it sounds very simple
but you would wonder how many people
don't do that in Xpress we have a way to
deal with that with middleware and I'm
going to go into that later cross-site
request forgery
see Cerf is incredibly popular where we
use the identity of the user to perform
requests on the user's behalf and
sometimes that's good because we would
actually want to do that for the user
and sometimes somebody does that without
actually the user agreeing towards it
right and we see a lot of different kind
of measurements against that like we see
nonce parameters state parameters we
synchronize the tokens and stuff like
that so we have weapons to deal with
this making sure that we don't suffer
under replay attacks and that kind of
stuff so there is things we can do which
is good so in this case we leverage with
sites trust in the user because the user
is locked in we have that kind of an
authentication so that seems to be legit
thing right
number nine is interesting because this
has whenever a code and everybody's like
oh I write great code and that is not
necessary
that causes me issues a good good
example was 2014 when hot plate was
released hardly it was a vulnerability
in open SSL about 17% of the trusted
internet was affected that is a lot
right so we have all those different
sites which kind of led to people
potentially reading the machines memory
which led to kind of a violation of
passwords all those passwords should be
invalidated and they are obviously not
so again we should move on and kind of
ditch password and get rid of them and
the last thing is kind of interesting
validating for boards and redirects on
our sites a lot of people block and they
use resources and they don't actually
check those resources over and over
again so even though our site might be
secure
we might lead people to an unsecured
site right and that might sound very
like well why would I care but sometimes
we actually have to care about these
things to make sure that works so there
is a table I'm not going to stick along
with that's too much but you can see
that some of those things are obviously
very easy to explore it some of them are
very widespread some of them are not
that widespread anymore because it's
getting easier it'd be easier to deal
with that stuff but still we want to
make sure that we look at at least those
top 10 if not even further and handle
that appropriately and there are
fantastic security modules which I'm
going to present that help you doing
that let's talk about hashing a lot of
people tend to think that it's enough to
use md5 sha-1 shahtoosh a free and so on
to do hashing of passwords or ciphertext
or anything like that and the user is
secure right because I've done my job
I've hash the password and that's it it
turns out that's not always the smartest
idea just this year a really really big
dating websites called Ashley Madison
got hacked and I want to point you to
the headline of the sides so it says
about 11 million passwords got leaked
there was just a developer that was
really keen
- just look at the password dump and
actually some code got leaked as well
and that developer found out that they
used bcrypt which is fantastic but 11
million passwords actually were just
simply hash with md5 and that lets who
those passwords being pretty much
correct in seconds the simple reason why
is md5 is actually way too fast it is an
incredibly efficient algorithm so we
want to look at slow algorithms that
help us kind of protecting data I there
is actually a bunch of really
interesting passwords in there and I
just want to point out four of them I
like I should not be doing this right
again it's a dating website then there
is why are you doing this so people are
very self-critical so passwords really
help us understand human beings there is
just trying this out sure sure you are I
love the best password ever and at least
for those top three that's how I felt
the first time when I tried the Milo
dinosaur I should not be doing this just
trying this out it's totally cool yeah
and now I drink that stuff every day
over here alright so obviously that is
an issue efficient hashing I said
pattern like those algorithms should be
slow and we see a big big reliance on
crypt blowfish pbkdf2 which stands for a
password-based key derivation function
and you can imagine a German accent I
had to learn that thing for like half an
hour repeating it over and over again to
say it flawlessly so those algorithms
are really slow and that's good let me
give you a good comparison so this is
coming from the Ruby bcrypt module and
they made a comparison between md5 and B
clips we talked about ten thousand
iterations and you can see that md5
blast through ten thousand results in
seconds right it not even a second it's
so fast it's so efficient various bcrypt
needs 22 seconds for exactly the same
data set right so that's for us
obviously a big indicator that big crap
might actually be a good choice
and I want to stress something that I
find really interesting we can actually
look at Ruby and especially at Rails
when we work with notes because they've
done a lot of mistakes that we do right
now already so we can actually prevent
making these mistakes we can look at
what they do we can look at their access
level control and so on and actually
learn from that but instead sometimes we
tend to reinvent the wheel instead of
just looking at existing technology and
using that as a role model started
hashing so now we obviously have a
cipher text a bit of data the password
and we want to hash that and that is
great but there is this thing called
rainbow tables where we use precomputed
hashes which means if I have that table
I can reverse-engineer passwords right
so what we do is we add a random bit to
it we add something completely random to
it we store that somewhere as well and
we make it harder to guess the original
password which leads to the interesting
side effect that even if 10 users in my
service have exactly the same passwords
we hash is not going to be the same
which is very very variable now there's
obviously these things that we can do we
can use hashing and that stuff but again
there must be other ways to harden our
apps because we don't just give a
passwords right and it turns out
javascript has actually really good
feature codes strict notes
so since ACMA script 5 we can actually
rely on function level or global level
scope strict modes which leads to
actually breaking the function
abstraction we can make sure that
certain errors are being thrown instead
of the abstract grace-filled
of really executing stuff it shouldn't
execute so we should always obviously a
neighbor strict note and that sounds
like a very simple bit of advice but you
would wonder how many people stay on
users reg X is a big enemy of execution
time if we handle the rack X and if we
validate input forms on our server side
we are stuck with the event loop and
that can lead to a fun few feature
like actually people ddossing our
services if I want to give you a very
long reg X that it's just very simply
hard to kind of compile and parse this
can actually lead to your app crashing
so there is a bunch of different things
that I can do and there are modules for
this and help you evaluate and reg X
before you actually run it on your van
loop so you are safe and you know
exactly what's going on
correct encoding that sounds like a very
simple thing but again we want to make
sure that nobody throws a couple of
scripts in there right so use that
ampersand use those hover kind of
characters and just do it and again
there are libraries which help you doing
that automatically did you ever look at
Express how a request body looks like
they populate the body by the thing they
call powered by and that's a bit of that
developer pride that we have developers
like to show of what we use right so
your app is telling every browser every
request exactly hey I run on Express and
that might sound cool if you're a
developer right because you want to be
to show off what you use and you use
your latest cool bit of technology but
it is actually not useful because we
want to not necessarily expose what our
stack runs on all right so this is a
very simple thing and I actually talked
recently to in a pen tester who said you
should just always change it to PHP so
this one can be hidden it is very simple
to just remove that or change it to
something your app actually doesn't run
on make it harder to get access to stuff
generating new IDs access tokens and all
that fun is really really important
still a lot of people don't actually
necessarily do it lots of people use
object IDs lot of let's say [ __ ] idea
MongoDB and they throw them away as
session cookie IDs and stuff like that
which might sound sensible it turns out
MongoDB is IDs are actually sequential
and they are guessable but we don't
necessarily want that right because if I
can guess your next session that is an
issue so we want to deal with stuff like
unique identifiers should be
non-sequential and it should be non
guessable note you your ID is a
fantastic really good module I highly
promise you it is one of the nicest
bcrypt modules I've seen parameter
pollution any kind of idea what's
happening if I submit the same parameter
twice this guy not see we know all right
so there we go instead of just having
the parameter renamed or just like fit
twice or something it's an array now if
I evaluate that and I rely on this not
being an array this can cause issues
again right so those are very simple
things same thing happens by the way for
post requests so expressed by default
populates arrays if there is more than
one parameter with the same name and you
should obviously avoid that as much as
you can be Crips I've been talking about
bcrypt I said I don't like md5 I also do
like s [ __ ] but I feel like decrypt is
easier to use big crypt turns a hash
into a salted hash and normally he would
store that sold separately now big [ __ ]
does a very interesting thing where it
uses dollar science as the limiter and
it actually stores we salt in the salted
hash so the first bit of this is the big
version then we have the number of
iterations that we execute on and then
we pass we hash and be salt
this is incredibly awesome the class we
don't actually have to care about
storing salt separately from the hatch
it's very awesome in terms of usability
and it's still secure generating a hash
can be done synchronously or a single
protein it is as simple as just using
this function and afterwards you just
compare the clear text ciphertext with
what you deem be valuable hash
incredibly easy to use it's there is no
learning curve at all CC surf like it
was preventing a sea surface X that used
to be embedded in Express they moved it
into a separate module to make it
easier to update that and not be bound
to my mayor version iterations see surf
generates a token we can define if this
token should be stored in this session
or in a cookie and then we populate we
recurse body by using a middleware so we
render a form like an input form or
something like that we pass on that
token and afterwards we actually check
if that form submits we talk again so
let's look at J template we actually see
I just provide this one parameter over
here and that's all I need to do so
instead of having users that are able to
resubmit the same form over and over
again it'll just work once after that
the token is invalidated and it's not
usable anymore I've done a major step in
securing my app and helping my users
there is this thing called helmet which
is a host food of security stuff you can
use most of those modules also a
standalone but it also comes as a
prepackaged thing so if you go to
helmets yes you will find out that it
allows you to kind of either trigger
some sensible default which is V button
initialization or you can use certain
features like turning off caching using
a cross-site scripting filter frame
guards which helps protecting iframes it
comes with content security policy it
comes with a lot of those kind of things
which might be a bit difficult to handle
on your site and it just does it for you
cool thing about helmet is it also works
a co-op and so if you're into that there
you go then Lascar that's actually a
module that paper has released it's part
of our croco suit and norske can be used
as a standalone which is very similar to
a helmet as well so you would mount it
as a middleware on the application level
of your app and it comes again with C
surf protection with content security
policy with frame guards PvP cross-site
scripting all these kind of good things
which we saw Leo as top 10 list right so
we don't necessarily always have to deal
with all the different issues it acts
actually sometimes are sensible to use
some of these kind of things
I cannot tell you what's better if you
should go for Hannah
Eliska look at both they are both really
popularity moments I think both are
great and Luca is also available for
Cora now both of them work is middleware
so we should probably look at middleware
there are three different types of
Express middleware that we can tap into
right application level and that is
something that we've seen just with
lower Lascar and with habit there is
root level stuff so we could probably
check if every user that goes to slash
admin is actually an admin or not and
then we can obviously do error handling
middle where we can create fully check
errors make sure those are our errors
and not pretty much just consumed in
somewhere and I'll really love our
Express handle sets because we can just
go from middleware to middleware to
middleware and gracefully go through
with chain of your friends kind of
functions so if you want to write a
custom middleware like an authentication
middleware the tracks is the users of
indicated it is as simple as writing a
new function that has a request a
response and an object called next which
is going to be the next function that's
going to be in a chain of commands you
just throw that into the get request or
to be post request and so on or you
mount it as application level which is
at the bottom this is really awesome I
think it is super variable and something
that can be used for a lot of different
things obviously not just authentication
and not just security an amazing example
for using this stuff is Passport anyone
use passport before
awesome so you have probably the guys
that's have been working with off and
off too before and we're like I can't
deal with this so passports comes what
is what they call strategies and
strategies can be a lot of different
things between I have a strategy for
connecting to a specific service like
Twitter or something more open like
let's say to a standard like or two so I
can say hey passport please use this off
to strategy talk to that server
and handle user login and authentication
authorization for me or I can define
what they call a local strategy which
comes down to more of the basic
authentication that we've done four
years already so if I want to do that I
want to draw your attention to two two
lines over here so this would be an
example using passwords with a local
strategy and MongoDB in order to handle
user authentication we see in the first
line that again we just use middleware
we initialize that middleware and we use
the local strategy which expects and
username and the password and all that
we really really care about is then
using that a different kind of methods
so if we look at the route like slash
login it obviously makes sense that we
go for passports authenticate which is
going to use the local strategy and then
in this local strategy if we perform
that if we find the user or if the user
name and the password match the request
body is going to be populated with a
couple of different details so it's
always in request dot user and that is
something that is very helpful at the
bottom you see that passport actually
comes with a bunch of different redirect
flows so passport even handles stuff for
you like invalid passport expired logins
and all that stuff which is really
really variable because you don't have
to do it on your site there is this
project that they call node secure node
security policy and node security
project and it is not just an amazing
block and a newsletter that tells you
about about different weaknesses and
issues that are floating around at the
moment but it is also a command-line
executable that you can install and that
is going to look at your package raisin
or at your shrink-wrap and tells you
about packages that you use that are
vulnerable at the moment or used to be
warned about so you can check if we code
that you use at the moment and all the
modules that you rely on our secure or
not and that is a very kind of useful
thing right and is super cheap to do it
is so easy
and a lot of people sadly don't know
about it yet so definitely have a look
at that I really enjoy using this then
we obviously talk about stuff like
passwords and we all kind of agree that
passports are not really usable
anymore passwords are no fun they have
all those kind of key issues that lead
to user data leaking so we look at our
authentication methods like let's say o
and we kind of agree that is good but
sometimes a bit clunky to implement and
sometimes it's just a bit too much
because sometimes I simply want to login
users so why don't we get rid of
passwords and go for password less of
Education there's actually two to three
companies that push this right now
amongst them is Twitter Yahoo and slowly
Facebook tends to go into the same
direction so they say why don't you just
use one-time tokens that are valid for a
couple of minutes that you receive yeah
via text message or a via email I use
those tokens I enter them I am logged in
and by doing that I skip all the issues
because replay attacks don't work
anymore the password that you sent me is
probably more secure than something that
I might come up with if I don't use a
password manager and the user experience
is actually pretty good so I feel like
password open as a hospitalist
authentication needs to get a bit more
attention because it is really a fun
user experience then there is this
project that is called the OAuth node
goat which is a big big project that
concentrates on highlighting different
issues so the top ten list that I've
been showing before with cross-site
scripting see surfer Tex injection and
so on they actually allow you to use a
real life application and to mess with
that application so you can try out
those vulnerabilities and it tells you
exactly how to fix them I highly
recommend going there checking it out it
is really valuable and it really helps
understanding these concepts much much
much better
then again note security I've been
talking on NSP which is the executable
that they have they have a newsletter
and they have a block so and they also
have a good Twitter account so you might
want to look at those two and subscribe
to it because it's a very easy way to
stay up to date I've been talking about
V Hydra initially and I said we are in
this treadmill with we are a bit like
donkey shot fighting a windmill it is an
endless struggle because we always have
a new thing coming up there's always a
new vulnerability a new version that
simply has a bug or something like that
and we have to keep up with that so we
can up our game very simply by using
this kind of advice learning from these
guys and simply applying what they tell
us we've been looking at a bunch of
different standards like all of open ID
oak mighty Kinect and they all try to
kind of cater to different form factors
if you look at all of one all of one
that then didn't even think about mobile
devices it didn't think about embedded
and fingerprint detection and all that
stuff that was simply not a thing back
then because that was 2007 oh of to the
mainframe work got released in 2012 and
a lot of strange since then as well open
ID is dead
open ID had more than a billion users at
its prime now if you go to my oak my
deed calm you will see that beside is
not even existent anymore but still
sometimes we need this accessible
service or a standard that works across
all different form factors from mobile
phone to desktop to the Internet
connected fridge and that's where Fido
seems to come in which is an alliance
between blackberry Google Microsoft
PayPal eBay a lot of different big big
companies that try to solve
authentication by either offering
password authentication or two-factor of
an occasion that is nicely standardized
and if we look at security we can
actually boil it down to a couple of
very very simple concepts if we look at
those mekin
and if we want to ensure that the user
stays safe and this is pretty much a
summary for to factor of negation we end
up with something the user has which can
be a token which can be a fingerprint
detector or something like that
something you know which can be your
password and something you are which
comes down again to your identity and
those three simple things they've been
floating around in the internet for
years already you will find articles
from Stanford and so on from back in
1995 we're very talk about these
concepts and they are still not really
popularly used with a bid I think that's
a bit of an issue and obviously we can
make it just harder to access our
services and we can enforce very hard
core passwords and we can make it really
horrible to use our service but that's
not what we want there's always a
trade-off between security and user
experience so we should try to not force
our users to suffer because we want to
protect the resources we can still
create delightful user experiences while
still protecting them and that's where
proper hashing for encryption where all
these things come in and I feel a lot of
those changes that I presented today are
really simple to implement they are
really really easy to kind of use and
they up our game they help us helping
our users and with that I want to leave
some time for questions thank you so
much for your attention thanks for
Thomas heavier for having me hi my name
is and you short these top 10 security
it starts right in my organization also
security team is very finicky about all
these so do we need to take care of all
these or you want to prioritize like
among all these ten they should be like
top five we should be really you know
fixing that so I feel like a lot of
those top ten issues that we looked at
before are actually very cheap wins for
us because they are very very easy to
deal with so if we look at our unknown
applications and a lot of the features
that express rings and where the
middleware comes in like passport like
helmet like Lowe's car and so on it is
actually very easy to deal with
right so I feel we should at least try
to cover those top ten and then even
look at the broader scope other issues
and see if we can do something on top of
what we do right now but the field those
top 10 are very very easy to deal with
right and a lot of them are actually
best practices like using strictmode
not just evaluating every regex that we
get those are sometimes very simple
things and very easy advice that just
simply needs to actually be followed
right so definitely have a look at those
security suits